why
so as we move towards a direction of
getting current with marvel comics as we
move towards this January first deadline
of leaving all these old stories behind
and getting current with current events
we pick up now with a death of Wolverine
issue number one and then what this will
do is it will go towards letting us
begin to get current it will let us go
towards the axis storyline and a lot of
these events that are going on at this
current time that do not include
Wolverine and so what we see as we start
this story is that Wolverine is speaking
directly with Reed Richards and Reed
Richards is analyzing the bone structure
and the physiological structure of
Wolverine and what he tells Wolverine is
god help him if he ever were to get a
concussion and the reason why is because
an order for a concussion to be relieved
a portion of the skull has to be cut out
in order to allow the brain to expand
and to allow the swelling to go down
but because Wolverine has an adamantium
or has adamantium lacing his bones this
would be basically impossible and so
what Wolverine does is he asked Reed
Richards to lay it out for him to
basically explain to him what's going on
and what we Richard says here is that
Wolverines healing factor is effectively
lost that it seems to be gone entirely
now if you guys want to know the events
behind why Wolverine had lost and lost
his healing factor we can of course do a
Marvel explained video about Wolverine
and we can discuss this topic but for
the most part I guess is a quick rundown
Wolverine was basically exposed to a
micro virus that has in fact suppressed
his healing factor it actually hasn't
eliminated it entirely and so what what
we richard says here is that the entire
structure the entire physical structure
of Wolverines body was built around the
idea that he could heal from anything he
was a prime candidate for the web 'next
program and to have his bones covering
adamantium because his body would be
able to heal from this or at least it
would have been able to but it can't do
that anymore and so what he says is that
Wolverines physical strength his stamina
and his speed is the only reason why
he's currently able to move around well
what what reverse also indicates here is
that while Wolverines healing factor
allowed him to heal from various wounds
that it was also acting as a suppress
of sorts and what it was doing was
suppressing the radiation in his bones
from his exposure to atomic radiation in
Nagasaki and so again without this
healing factor his body will begin to
undergo the process of effective
radiation poisoning but what he also
says is that when Wolverine had popped
his claws that most likely he had been
exposed to all different kinds of
bacteria to say nothing of the blood of
other people that he had on his claws
whenever his claws were brought back
into his body again and so who knows no
one really knows what kind of substances
what kind of diseases Wolverine may
currently have at the moment
now why trait Richards also says is that
he can solve this problem for Wolverine
but it would require that that raid
Richard speak with Tony Stark with Hank
McCoy but what will very says here is
he's already talked to those individuals
and that Reed Richards was the last
genius on his list now Reed Richards as
he says doesn't really take this
personal because they haven't been very
close but he tells Wolverine that he can
solve this problem for him he can figure
out what it is that can I guess they can
be done to eliminate this virus inside
the body of Wolverine and reactivate his
healing factor but it'll take time that
Wolverine is going to have to stop
fighting that he's basically gonna have
to lay low for a while but Wolverine
says this is not an option and the
reason isn't necessarily because
Wolverine wants to go out and fight
people but it's because once the world
begins to realize that Wolverine doesn't
have a healing factor anymore that
people are going to start putting
contracts out on him and people that
want to see him killed or going to try
to get other people to have him killed
and so there's basically as Wolverine
explains it it's going to be open season
here and so what rebid says is that if
this is the case if people are going to
start coming after Wolverine then of
course will rain should keep himself
alive and fight them off
but under no circumstances should
Wolverine use his claws and so what we
do is we switch to a place called Eric's
pub and Eric's pub is a place that
Wolverine had visited on several
occasions where the bartender is very
much familiar with Wolverine and what
the bartender tells Wolverine is that he
hadn't seen him for quite some time and
he asked him whether or not he wants a
once a beer or not
now Wolverine says to give the give the
the bartender the whole bottle and not a
glass and he asked for a couple of rags
as well as his phone and what we see is
that as Wolverine is I guess sitting
down at the bar that he uses the alcohol
to wrap some I guess to add I guess pour
on some bandages and to wrap his a hand
with those bandages indicating that he's
trying to heal the wounds on his hands
where his claws come out but what he
also does is he picks up the phone and
calls someone now we don't know who this
person is but it seems as though there's
somewhat of a relatively friendly
conversation going on here Wolverine in
this person of course you're talking
about Battlestar and so on and so forth
but as wolf rain begins to converse with
this person and what we find out is that
Wolverine is not going to tell this
person where he's at and the whole
reason why he had called them was
because he just wanted a friendly
conversation and so what happens here is
Wolverine hangs up the phone and wolven
tells the bartender that he'll take a
glass after Robby he'll take a shot of
beer just for the road but what he also
says is that people are going to come
looking for him and that this will most
likely be the first place that they look
and the bartender initially asked
Wolverine whether these will be friends
but Wolverine says they're not going to
be and so what happens as Wolverine
leaves the bar and we don't find out
directly what it is that Wolverine had
said to the partner if anybody comes
looking for him but what we do is we
transition to a couple days later and an
individual surrounded by what appear to
be three henchmen up here to the
bartender and tell the bartender they're
looking for some kind of some kind of
drink now the bartender asked them what
it is they want and this person says it
doesn't matter as long as it's American
now this person as is revealed to us is
a man named nuke
now nuke was a person who had been
created during the Vietnam era but have
been created to more or less be a
Vietnam era version of Captain America
but over the course of nukes
I guess comic book appearances over the
course of his history while he initially
had started out as a person he had been
subjected to various I guess artificial
and cybernetic enhancements which had
basically turned him into a cyborg which
of course includes his head being a
cybernetic head as well as a very other
various other portions of his body but
what the bartender does is he hands nuke
three beers but also pulls out a
Remington shotgun from under the under
the countertop and what on what nuke
does is he hands the bartender $200 and
the bartender asks him what's it's for
what it what is it for and nuke says
that 16 of the dollars are for the beers
and the rest of the money
for the gun that's going to have to be
repurchased when newt grabs the barrel
of the shotgun and bends it and so what
he tells the bartender is other looking
for someone they're looking for a
shorter guy who calls himself logan and
that this would be the kind of place
that he would hang out at and he asked
the bartender whether he seen him or not
now the bartender says yes he says that
he's seen logan that he's gone but that
that logan also said that these people
would come for him and that honestly
there's probably no way they could catch
up to him in time but again when Luke
asked him whether or not Logan had said
anything else
the bartender hands him a piece of paper
that Logan had left him and when the
piece of paper is unfolded it has an X
on an island indicating that Wolverine
is inviting these individuals to come
and find him and so what happens is we
transition to Nuuk alongside his three
henchmen as they're analyzing the island
and what they see is that there's some
kind of a boat that's been I guess
that's tied to the to the docks here
most likely a boat that Wolverine had
used to get to this island and so what
we see is that nuke tells one of the
henchmen to get on a raft then to go
check out the boat and as the henchman
is analyzing this boat as the henchman
is going through and looking at this
boat he boards it and the boat suddenly
explodes and so we transitioned back to
Nuuk who says that's why you only have
one person check out the boat so you
don't lose your forces all at one time
but then we Ginn to begin to see the
boat that they're currently standing on
it starts rocking back and forth
most likely because it's being attacked
but then the boat begins to sink
indicating to us that most likely
Wolverine has used this cause and attack
the boat from underneath and so what
happens is nuke along with the other two
henchmen bail out and they begin to swim
to shore now as they're swimming to
shore we see that one of the henchmen is
presumably attached from underneath and
blood begins to show in the water which
indicate that Wolverine has killed this
henchman and then we see the same thing
happened to the second one and so nuke
is the only one who's made it to shore
by himself and so what happens here is
that once he gets to shore he looks up
and he realizes that there are a litany
of bodies spread all over the place now
some of these bodies are cybernetic some
of these bodies are human but most of
their faces are covered up however the
some of them appear to be part of the
same group indicating that maybe they
had all arrived here at the same time
and indeed this is what Wolverine says
when he appears behind Newt
he says half of the people here had
taken each other out just trying to get
to Wolverine they were most likely
fighting over the over whatever it was
or the whole reason behind why they were
here and he says the other half died
because they fight they wanted to fight
instead of having a conversation with
Wolverine and so what happens is nuke
immediately goes after Wolverine and
tries to attack him but again Wolverine
is able to hold his own relative against
the onslaught of nuke but only in so far
that he's able to withstand the damage
that nuke is dealing out to him now what
new tells Wolverine here is something
very very important he tells Wolverine
that it's not his contract and he's not
the one that put the kill order out on
Wolverine but he says whatever whoever
was it put this kill order out who put
this contract out had made it absolutely
massive that word is out all over the
world to every bounty hunter and anyone
out there who has a dislike for
Wolverine that there is a massive amount
of money for a person that brings
Wolverine in but he doesn't indicate
whether or not this is dead or alive and
so what happens is again as the two of
them begin begin talking as Wolverine
begins asking us questions again while
at the same time fighting nuke he asked
the question of who it was that put out
this kill order of who it was that had
ordered Wolverine be killed but nuke
says that it's not a kill order they
don't want move reign dead that
Wolverine is wanted alive and that not
only is he wanted alive but anybody who
brings Wolverine in dead is not even
going to be paid for the reward that the
only way to be paid the amount of money
that's being offered for Wolverine is to
bring him and alive and so he says that
this is basically a race because there
are so many people out to capture
Wolverine that everybody is trying to
get to him as fast as they possibly can
and so he says there's really nowhere
Wolverine can go there's really nothing
he can do to keep himself safe from
anybody out there and so again what he
tells nuke here is two things
he tells nuke 1 that anybody that shows
up here is going to kill is going to die
at the hands of Wolverine and 2 that
Wolverine isn't isn't any kind of a
prize that this bounty needs to come to
an end and so what he says is that nuke
is going to be the last person that he
allows to leave alive that if anybody
else shows up coming after Wolverine
that
going to die now what he also does is he
asks again nuke who it was that had done
this he asked who it was that had set
out this bounty and nuke says that the
contract had come out of Matt rapport
and when Wolverine asked who it was it
had issued this contract nuke refers to
this person as a the individual who's
running poison city that this person is
referred to as a Green Queen indicating
to us of the person who would most
likely put out this bounty on Wolverine
is Viper with that being said we're
going to go ahead and bring this video
to an end I hope you guys enjoyed it if
you did let me know and I will catch you
guys later